Continuing
[Silence]
in the 68th chapter
of the book of Allah Quran
various names
and we have
reached to the we have arrived at the
fourth verse.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is addressing the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam
in this verse and the previous verses
to review. We'll take it from the
beginning because all of these verses
are very closely tied into one another.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says noon
I swear by the pen and what they write
and all that they write.
You, oh messenger, oh Muhammad, are not
by the grace of your Lord in any way
insane or mad.
And I further swear that for you is an
is a great and
unending a vast and unending reward.
And I further swear that you, oh
messenger, oh Muhammad,
are upon
a high level
and esteemed
level and stature of etiquette and
character.
So we look at these verses we see that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is defending
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
He is affirming for him the highest with
respects to
intelligence.
He is
insinuating
that he sallall.aii wasallam
should
be patient with the difficulties that he
is encountering from his antagonist.
He assures the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam. That for him is a very vast and
unending
reward.
foreign
[Silence]
There is no
for
[Silence]
ahead. Foreign
speech. Foreign foreign foreign speech.
[Silence]
Good try though, right?
Listen to it.
Tenwin,ch.
[Silence]
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives
two descriptions of this great reward.
He he describes the reward itself as
being incredible, vast,
grand,
and he also describes it as being
unending.
Because no matter how good something is,
if it comes to an end, what was the
what was the point? What do you get to
take away from that? there has to be
something that is remnant that
remains.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala often
brings these two descriptions together
in the Quran that
the he says for instance in
the the hereafter is better than the and
it is
it is better in itself and it is
unending in its time span. It has no
end.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then follows
this up by saying
[Silence]
He a little kid
inch.
[Silence]
sliding. That's exactly it. This lamb is
referred to as the sliding lamb.
It's been it's been slided.
And the reason they call it that is
because it actually moved
from
or
this lamb always comes with
it always comes with it and it
slides over from
to the for a number of reasons. The
point is is that this lamb what is the
point of it? The point of it is
to add emphasis.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is saying
and indeed you oh Muhammad are upon
great etiquette and character. Now when
I
speak when anyone speaks to a listener
when a speaker adds
words of emphasis
what does that reflect about the
listener?
Okay. Importance number one, but what
else?
we have a number of emphas
emphasis things that emphasize this
in emphatic
letters or statements. So we have
first Allah swears by the pen and all
that they used to write with it. That's
number one. Number two, we have in and
this is used to emphasize. Number three,
we have the
and this is also used to emphasize. It's
almost you could summarize this as being
indeed indeed indeed you are upon a high
level of etiquette. So when I emphasize
something that as a speaker,
this emphasis will only come number one
with something that is very important.
But number two, if the listener
doesn't believe it or the statement is
so great that you might not believe it,
right?
Yeah. I mean the the reason is is that
if I come and say to you for instance
Ahmed is coming right Ahmed is coming
but if I come and say
indeed Ahmed is coming
I swear by Allah indeed Ahmed is coming.
I swear by Allah indeed verily I
proclaim that Ahmed is coming
all of this emphasis for what reason
here is the reason and I want this this
has a point this isn't just shen this
isn't just you know fel this has a
point why am I saying all of this
when you look at society
and Can you see that we have idioms, we
have proverbs
that look down on people who have good
character. What do I mean by that? If I
say for instance, nice guys finish
last.
Nice guys finish last. This is positive
or negative. This is negative. What
about if I say if we say for instance
mercy is for thee
the weak
right these are things that we say
idioms proverbs that we say common
phrases that are almost spoken as
truisms because society only without the
guidance of Allah look at these kinds of
things and they see it to be weakness,
forgiveness, pardon, patience,
right? They say if if you're that,
everyone's going to take advantage of
you. As a matter of fact, this has also
made its way into the Muslim psychology.
for instance in Phil where I grew
up they will say about someone that he's
religious they say
mskh
he's he prays he's he's just a you
know he's just a a poor guy he's right
because we have this stigma you know
what the stigma is that if you if you
learn Learn the Quran, learn the Sunnah,
and follow it. You're not really very
clever.
Clever and cunning and intelligence.
Those attributes are always given to the
scum. Someone who can swindle people
really good, really good liars, right?
Those guys say, "Wow, it's not good what
he's doing, but boy is he clever. Boy,
is he smart." They don't give those
attributes to people that follow the
Sunnah.
They give those attributes to who?
[Arabic recitation]
for you to walk across the street to
spit on. People that aren't worth two
two cents, two black cents. But then we
make movies about them and we marvel at
their intelligence and their cunning and
their right. But when we look at, you
know, how often do you see a movie or a
song or a where the guy is patient and
forgiving and pardoning and overlooking
and that's not an interesting movie.
[Arabic recitation]
jilted 50 years ago and plans 50 years
worth of revenge until finally he gets
his revenge. Right? or a guy that
manages to swindle a whole bunch of
money out and we write these people's
history. We almost exalt them. Kids want
to be them. We put their pictures
up, their posters up in our bedrooms,
right? Because righteousness
and intelligence
in our society today, those are not
those are considered to be antonyms.
Those are not synonyms. Those are
considered to be antonyms.
If you are someone that even amongst the
Muslim,
don't think that it's not there. Even
amongst the Muslim, this is the strain
of
that is found amongst the Muslim.
What did the used to say about the
prophet Sam?
Huh?
[Silence]
Right.
This is how the hypocrites look down on
the companions
and they used to mock them, right?
Right. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
reassures the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam. Your patience is not an action
and your lack of revenge
is not because you don't notice.
Your overlooking
doesn't mean you're not intelligent. You
see, you see what's happening. You know,
but you are of a higher level than these
folks down here,
right? They look down on you because you
pardon them, because you forgive,
because you don't retaliate,
because you don't make fun of them like
they make fun of you,
and they look at you you are a
simpleton,
a fool.
But really,
and notice the wording here.
You are upon
a high
vast level of character.
You're far above these guys. Don't let
them bring you down. Don't let them
their insults really get to you and make
you think that because you're choosing
not to go down to their level that
somehow this is because you are weak or
because you are unintelligent.
No. And this is a a parody. You can even
see in in Muslim countries,
you can watch the, you know, , Arab
cinema where they show, you know, ,
religious guys. They make fun of them
they're kind of dumb, they're a
little bit stupid, they're kind of
foolish,
right?
But then the really intelligent
folks, no, they don't worry about this
Quran and Sunnah stuff. Those guys, they
will plot and plan and they're the ones
that get ahead. They're the ones that
get the dramatic music and soundtrack,
right? They're the ones who have
dramatic takes of their words.
But the religious, those are kind of
foolish people. Exactly what the said
about the prophet and his companions.
[Silence]
That's how they are. That's what the
hypocrites think of the people that
carry Allah's words in their heart. They
see them as simple.
And any Muslim
who perpetuates or pedals this concept
of those who fear Allah is upon the
sunnah of their ancestors of
Abdullahb
and his companions, the hypocrites of
Medina. Those are their ancestors, the
ones that make fun of the followers of
Allah and his messenger. But
he understood.
He said,
he said, "I'm neither a slimy reptile,
nor does the slimy reptile trick me.
Just because I overlook doesn't mean I
didn't see.
Just because I choose not to retaliate
doesn't mean I'm weak. Just because I
show patience doesn't mean I'm I am
exhibiting inaction.
No,
restraint takes strength.
Mercy comes from a place of power.
And pardon comes from a place of
intelligence.
And in the narration of
we'll end with this, we remember the
narration
of
when the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam gave her the analogy and said
you and I are Abu Z and
except that I'm not going to divorce
you. Abu Zar divorced and there's a long
narration where these different women
describe their husbands. But one woman
described her husband. She said,
She gave three descriptions.
She said, "When he comes in the house,
he's a panther.
When he leaves the house, he's a
lion,
and he doesn't ask about what he left
behind." What does she mean by this?
She describes her husband saying when he
comes home,
he is a panther. You know, every
culture they take animals
and they take a characteristic about
that animal and they use it to describe
people. for instance, if I say
lion, what comes to mind? What
description?
[Arabic recitation]
right? What about if I say snake?
Slimy, cunning, deceptive, right?
Treacherous, right? What about if I say
rat?
Lowly. What if I say cockroach?
[Arabic recitation]
If the if the world blew itself up,
cockroaches would come out the next day,
right?
The Arabs have the same thing in their
literature, in their fables.
So, one of the descriptions is a
panther.
A panther in the Arab in the Arabic
culture
is is refer is used as a reference
for
the Arabs view the panther as being an
animal that
doesn't notice a lot around it. It's
kind of it's kind of u
It's not the It's not the the
sharpest knife in the drawer, right? And
the thing is is that it it overlooks it.
It It only worries about certain things.
And it it's a it's a creature that is
known to overlook, right? It's referred
to it's a it's an example
or an analogy of
a lion is an analogy for strength and
and courage. Okay. So what she's saying
is that when my husband comes home
with me, he's a panther.
meaning that he doesn't pick on every
little thing and he doesn't notice every
little mistake. He overlooks. It's not
cuz he doesn't see. He sees. But he's
above pettiness.
He lets me get away with things that no
one else can get away with. But when he
goes out into the public, now he's a
lion. Nobody no one gets away with him.
Right. And when he leaves something
behind, he never brings it up again.
What's that mean? Meaning he'll
bring home a pound of chicken. And she
says, "Hey, pick up chicken on your way
home." I just brought a pound. What
happened to the chicken? Where did it
go? Right. We need some rice. What
are you drinking the rice? Where'd it
go? I just bought some two days ago.
Right. Always checking. Always counting
every bite.
This is a reference to his generosity.
So we see that these are chosen
characteristics. They're good character.
Meaning that this person,
he treats his family, his wife in that
way, right? And this is a praise for
him. The prophet sallall.aii
am is getting even higher praise than
this.
Don't worry about what they say. They
make fun of you. They they speak ill
about you. They they they mock you.
They look down on you. They come to you
and they say, "I swear by Allah, I was
unable to join the party." Right?
Meaning the the to go to war, to battle,
right? the they would come and say, "I
swear by Allah,
right? They would come up with some
bogus excuse and say, "I swear by
Allah." And the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would just take him at
their word and let him go. So they'd
make fun of him.
They'd say he he's he's an open
ear. He just listens to everyone and he
doesn't know the difference between
people who are swindling him and people
who are truthful to him. But here Allah
is telling him that's not because he
doesn't know. No, he sees. He sees
everything.
He knows.
However, he is above that
and he deals with people based on the
law of Allah.
Abu Bakr,
we'll end with this.
He was with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and a man started to berate him
and insult him. Abu Bakr was patient
and then he started to
defend himself and retaliate. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam left him
and walked off. So Abu Bakr asked him
you know this guy was this guy was
you know berating me and you you stayed
for that. Then when I started to defend
myself you left me. He said, "There was
an angel standing there defending you,
but when you started to retaliate, he
left. So I left, too. I wouldn't sit in
the company where angels wouldn't sit."
These are the That takes strength. That
takes courage. Courage to pardon someone
even though
that person may come back to to hurt
you. When Omar brought Abul al-Musi,
he threatened him. He threatened him
just a week before he murdered him. He
threatened him. And Omar knew he was
threatening him. Did Omar say, "Okay,
guys, we need to have 10 guards on two
shifts, five guards, five guards. Take
this guy, put him in prison, disappear
him. I'm afraid for my life. I'm No."
The guy came and he attacked Omar Wen in
his most vulnerable state when he's
leaving
because that takes strength,
takes courage to not oppress someone out
of fear,
[Arabic recitation]